[Musique]
les messieurs la présidente de la 43e
cérémonie des césar
mademoiselle vanessa paradis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en soirée ce soir je suis très heureuse
et très impressionné d'être ici avec
vous ce soir c'est vrai c'est
impressionnant des deux rangs tant
d'artistes de créateurs
c'est émouvant je sais que beaucoup
d'entre vous et d'autres qui ne sont pas
là ce soir se bat pour faire des films
et qu'on voit pour parler d'autres
combats des batailles pour l'émotion
pour la tendresse pour le rire
alors je voudrais vous remercier de vous
battre pour tout ce que vous inspirer
chaque jour à vous je voudrais dire
bravo vous avez tous fait un film cette
année vous pouvez être si fier parce que
c'est incroyable de faire un film
il n'y a pas de meilleur et ajuste des
différences c'est une année chargée
comme souvent dans notre cinéma français
parce que il est si riche et si variés
et m'a encore fait rire aux larmes remet
révolté fait prendre conscience de moi
même et des autres
ils me rappellent souvent qui je suis
est-ce que j'oublie souvent d'être emm
donne le moral
imhof des rêves et souvenirs des pères
du courage des féminins de la force
ses derniers mots me font beaucoup
penser à jamais j'ai eu la chance de
tourner un film avec elle et ce qui m'a
épaté hormis le fait donner la réplique
à l'une des plus grandes actrices au
monde
c'était d'observer chez elle que ça
barde féminin était égal à sa part ii
masculins que ça lui donnait cette grâce
et cette force si impressionnante
c'est un équilibre qu'une fille souvent
rêver
ce soir je porte sur une bande blanche
comme beaucoup d'autres ici en soutien à
la lutte des vieux contre les violences
faites aux femmes
et bien entendu contre les violences
faites à chacun il est temps de célébrer
le cinéma français
je vous souhaite une très belle soirée
une très belle soirée
et je déclare ouverte la 43e cérémonie
des césar
merci rennais ça bravo